- Welcome all of you
to the MacMillan Center
here at Yale University.
So the MacMillan Center is
Yale's multidisciplinary
multi-school international
convening center
for all kinds of international studies.
We train people in languages,
the histories, the societies,
and the politics of lots
of different countries
across the world,
and America's relationship with them.
We have seven area studies councils here,
the largest of which,
and I would say one of
the most active of which
is the East Asian Studies Council,
which is increasingly doing more on Korea.
And then we have various initiatives
on a whole slew of different issues,
including an environmental issue,
very relevant to today's topic,
headed by Nobel
prize-winner Bill Nordhaus.
So today we're going to celebrate
the Coca-Cola World Fund Lecture.
This is a lecture that was established
by the Coca-Cola Foundation
in the early 1990s.
It's one of the highlights
of our academic year.
We bring in world leaders,
influential public figures
to discuss the world's
most pressing issues
and to interact with faculty and students
from across the Yale community.
Previous lectures include
people like Mary Robinson,
the President Ireland.
Raghuram Rajan, who was the
Chief Economist at the IMF,
and then the head of the
Reserve Bank of India.
Raila Odinga, the Prime Minister of Kenya,
as well as leading public intellectuals,
such as Thomas Friedman.
So to introduce our very
distinguished guests today,
I'd like to invite up
professor Hwansoo Kim,
who is the chair of the
East Asian Studies Council.
Our largest area studies
cancel here at Yale.
Hwansoo.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, Steve.
It's a great honor
to again welcome
Secretary-General Ban Ki-Moon
to Yale University.
And it also our pleasure
to welcome the Secretary General's wife,
Mrs. Yoo Soon-taek and
his daughter Ban Hyun-hee.
Could you just briefly raise your hand,
Mrs. Yoo first.
(audience clapping)
And then daughter Ban Hyun Hee,
and his son Ban Woo-hyun.
(audience clapping)
And also former US ambassador Kim Sung,
which yeah, here we go.
(audience clapping)
So we are especially grateful
that our guests have taken time
out of their really busy schedules
to fly all the way from
Korea to be here us today.
When I first talked to the
Secretary-General via phone,
I think last November
to extend an invitation,
my motive was primarily
to raise the profile
of Korean studies at Yale.
The Secretary-General
accepted the invitation
without hesitation, but
as I hung up the phone,
I thought, what have I done?
The Korean Studies
Program is far too small
to host a figure of such stature,
and thankfully, I would
rescued by Steven Wilkinson,
the Director of MacMillan Center,
who enthusiastically took over
the coordination of such
a high-profile event.
So I'd like to thank Steven first
and all those staff at
the MacMillan Center,
as well as those on the
Council on East Asian Studies
who worked very hard to
make today's event possible.
As chair of the Council
in East Asian Studies,
it is my pleasure to
introduce our guest of honor.
Born in Korea, Mr. Ban
received a bachelor's degree
in International Relations
from Seoul National University in 1970.
He earned a master's degree
in Public Administration
from the Joan F. Kennedy
School of Government
at Harvard University in 1985.
As all of us know, Mr. Ban
served two consecutive terms
as the Secretary-General
of the United Nations
from 2007 to 2016.
Throughout his tenure at the UN
Mr. Ban strove to be a breeze builder,
to give voice to the world's poorest,
and most vulnerable people,
and to make the organization
more transparent and effective.
He successfully pressed for
action to combat climate change,
an effort that culminated in
the adoption and rapid entry
into the landmark Paris Agreement in 2016.
Mr. Ban worked closely with
member states of the UN
to shape the 2030 agenda
for sustainable development
and to establish UN women
which had been advancing
the organization's work
for gender equality and
women's empowerment.
Mr. Ban also launched major efforts
to strengthen UN peace operations,
to protect human rights,
to improve humanitarian response,
to prevent violent extremism
and to revitalize this disarmament agenda.
At the time of his appointment at the UN,
Mr. Ban was the minister of
foreign affairs and trade
of the Republic of Korea.
His 37 years with the ministry
included postings in New
Delhi, Washington, D.C,
and Vienna and responsibilities
for a variety of portfolio,
including Foreign Policy
Advisor to the President,
Chief National Security
Vice Minister, Deputy
Minister for policy planning
and Director-General for American Affairs.
Mr. Ban has also been actively involved
in issues relating to
inner Korean relations
by serving as Chairman of
the Preparatory Commission
for the Comprehensive
Nuclear-Test-Ban Treaty Organization
After he finished his two terms
as the UN Secretary-General,
Mr. Ban served as chairman
of Presidential National Council
on Climate and Air
Quality from 2019 to 2021.
In 2018, he was elected as chairman
of Boao Forum for Asia.
Mr. Ban, along with former
President of Austria,
Mr. Heinz Fischer was
inducted as a co-chair
of the Ban Ki-moon Center
for Global Citizens
in Vienna, Austria.
Mr. Ban is the Chair of the
Global Center on Adaptation,
an international organization
hosted by the Netherlands.
He was also elected the
chairman of IOC Ethics Committee
in September 2017.
Mr. Ban served as the Honorary Chairman
at the Institute for Global
Engagement & Empowerment
at Yonsei University in
Korea from 2018 to this year.
In February 2018, he was elected,
and has been serving as the
President of the Assembly
and Chair of the Council of
Global Green Growth Institute.
Currently, he is Chairman
of Ban Ki-moon Foundation
For a Better Future and
Distinguished Chair,
Professor and Honorary Chairman
of the Future Strategy Institute
at Seoul National University.
So Mr. Ban's current efforts
reside in addressing the
major global struggles
of climate change, the pandemic,
and sustainable development.
So what is passed
the most international
perspective conceivable,
Mr. Ban will be speaking on
these pressing issues today.
So without further ado,
please join me welcoming
our distinguished speaker,
Secretary-General, Ban Ki-Moon.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, Professor Steven Wilkinson,
Director of MacMillan Center,
and Professor Kim Hwansoo,
Chair of the Asian Studies Council.
Thank you for your very warm introduction.
I'm incredibly honored
to follow the footsteps
of many luminaries
and deliver this Coca-Cola World Fund
at the Yale University.
Dear students and faculty
members, ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you very much again for
your very kind introduction.
In fact, you have preempted
most of the topics
which I was going to say.
So, I dunno how much I can add to this.
Again, in any way is a great honor for me
to be with you today,
and try to discuss and share,
first of all, my vision
and my experience and try to
discuss this matter with you.
I was given about 45 minutes.
I hope that these 45 minutes
will not make anybody sleep.
I hope it will not make
you a little bit tired.
I'd like to speak about
first the COVID 19 pandemic,
and climate change and carbon neutrality,
and global citizens.
After my lecture,
I will open up the floor
for some questions,
which you may have.
I'm sorry that my voice has,
I've been speaking all
day long since yesterday.
So this is my last occasion
since during last one week.
So I hope you'll understand my condition.
Indeed, I have wonderful
memories of my April 16 visit
to this very distinguished university
where under my initiative,
United Nations has been convening
sort of colloquium of
University Presidents
while dealing with climate change
and other global agendas.
We just wanted to have wisdom
and some advices from university
academic institutions.
So Yale University President Salovey
was one of the six Presidents
on whom we really depended
upon their guidance and wisdom,
and academic intellectual
knowledge on climate change
and human rights and
sustainable development
and women's empowerment
and all the global agendas
United Nations were handling
and hoping to achieve.
In there, I met the President
Salovey this morning
a little bit and expressed
my deepest of thanks again,
after many years after my retirement.
And again, I thank very much.
I hope our discussions
today will also help me,
even though I'm a private
citizen, as was introduced,
I'm holding at least more than a dozen,
a dozen international positions.
So you can use my voice
if you have anything.
I have a lot of avenues and way to deliver
and raise the problems
of our global problems
to the public and global leaders.
Now, six years later
as a new senseless war of aggression
in Ukraine has been killing civilians,
forcing billions of Ukrainian citizens.
According to UNESCO
resulting in the damage
and destruction of at least
53 cultural sites in Ukraine,
since the Russian invasion began.
I feel my words at Yale University,
and I have been speaking loud
and clearly in my capacity
as Vice Chairman of the
Elders Organization,
private organization
founded by Nelson Mandela
and composed of just 10 global leaders,
of former presidents and
Nobel Peace laureates.
And I'm working as the
vice-chairman of that.
And we have strongly condemned
this illegal and unacceptable
aggression of Ukraine.
So this is a part of the configurations,
but it is now affecting
all spectrums of our life,
including peace and security,
and development and human right issues.
Dear student and faculty members,
today, we find ourselves
at the center of variety
of converging crisis
and increased uncertainty.
The ongoing COVID 19 pandemic
continues to append our economies,
societies and way of life.
Great power tensions are surging,
and ongoing conflict in Ukraine
represents one of the
most dangerous moments
for global security in decades
with a profound humanitarian
and economic repercussions.
At the same time, our planet is on fire
literally and figuratively.
With the climate crisis deepening,
as the global temperature arising,
flood rage and wildfires burn.
COVID 19 and other global crisis
such as climate change
have underlined our
fundamental interconnectedness.
No country is an island.
Nobody's free from these global threats.
They have also made it clear
that we need global solutions
born out of cooperation and
partnership, and sustainability
to address the global
challenges that we face.
No country, however
powerful and resourceful
just like United States can
solve these challenges alone.
We need to forge a stronger
tripartite partnership.
That means government,
business communities,
and civil society,
maybe you may belong to civil society now,
but some of you will be joining
government and businesses.
Therefore, these tripartite partnership
is the most important
to make sure that our
society becomes sustainable.
I believe that COVID 19 has
also offered us a glimpse
of the global disruptions
that will arise from climate
change in the near future.
These include elevated
public health perils,
mass displacement,
turmoil to supply chains,
and increased conflict and
projected economic crisis.
Both pandemics and climate
change are global issues,
which will require a strong multi-response
and international
cooperation and partnership
as I have stated.
Under this spectrum of
COVID 19, planetary crisis,
conflict, and teasing changes,
we have also made progress in key areas,
and I know that we have
vital opportunities
to change the worlds for the better.
That is why I have established
Ban Ki-Moon Foundation
For a Better Future.
This is a small foundation.
This is the only personal foundation
which I have founded,
but I'm just working to
make even small contribution
to make our future better, better for all.
But to do so, again,
we must come together in solidarity
and to beat COVID 19 and
urgency, take climate actions.
We must redouble our efforts
to leave up to the guiding ideals
of the United Nations Charter
and it's a pledge to, I quote,
"Save the succeeding generations
from the scourge of war."
This is the first line
when our forefathers
established United Nations.
And this is the first line
of the United Nations,
Why?
They were committed after Second World War
to establish the United Nations.
We must enhance protection
of civilians during wars,
as well as the refugees
that those wars make.
We must strive to better
emphasize prevention
as a mechanism to address
armed conflict and suffering.
And we must go further in
bolstering international justice
and accountability in
the face of war crimes.
Dear students, ladies, and gentlemen,
I'd like to begin by providing
you with a bit of an overview
on the wide-ranging global disruptions
and impact of this global pandemic.
Now into is our third year,
COVID 19 pandemic continues
to alter our personal lives,
communities, and the world itself.
With the nearly 515 million global cases
and at least 6.2 million
tragic global death,
this pandemic has caused immense suffering
and serious challenges
all around the world.
The richest and biggest
country United States
also had 81.4 million cases
and almost 1 million death.
COVID 19 has precipitated oversize impact
on global economic growth
and pronounced supply
and demand disruptions.
Such as supply chain
issues are now worsening
because of the crisis in Ukraine.
COVID 19 has also amplified
existing inequalities in health,
labor, housing, food,
gender, and other key areas.
These impacts, alongside rising inflation
have converged to create
the most significant
global social-economic crisis
since The Great Depression.
For example, the United Nations estimates,
the COVID 19 cost 225
million full-time jobs
in the year 2020 alone.
The Global Network Against Food Crises
says that the number
of food-insecure people
is now at 155 million persons,
a five-year high as a
result of the pandemic.
And UNICEF warns that one-third
of the world of children
are unable to access remote learning
during school closures.
Under this troubling backdrop
of the global development landscape,
it is clear that ongoing recovery
will be both extended and urge us.
And this is particularly true
as vaccine and therapeutic inequity
continues to extend the
pandemic for so many
all around the world,
particularly those in
developing countries.
To ensure that we recover correctly,
it is not enough to build back.
We must build back better
as well as greener.
Currently, as you may know,
I'm serving as President of the Assembly
of International Organization
called Global Green Growth Institute,
which is headquartered in Korea
with the 43 member states.
Indeed our recovery from COVID 19
most simultaneously
address climate action.
Climate action, climate change,
and COVID 19 are the
two sides of one coin.
It is tightly corrected.
We have to understand
there is a connected interconnectedness
between all the global challenges.
Doing so will go a long
way in helping to guide us
towards a more sustainable
and resilient carbon neutral
for all people and our planet.
With this in mind,
I formally believe that
the international community
must actively scale-up
global leadership and cooperation
in the sphere of public health.
We must also expand preparedness
in anticipation of both the
next waves and next pandemics.
Modern pandemics are
increasingly interrelated
to biodiversity loss
and closer interaction
between humans and animals.
I came to New York and here yesterday
from my visit to Colombia.
Colombia is one of the
rich biodiversity country.
I think they are the
second only to Brazil.
I flew over this forestry, deep forestry,
and just one national park,
one national park should taken.
I was surprised to find out, first of all,
the size of this national park.
I was told that there are 62 such parks
with the forestry.
The size of one park
was half of South Korea.
I was just stunt.
While I was very much
impressed by the huge forestry,
but I was also sad
to have seen so many areas deforested.
This is a very sad,
this will really cause
climate temperature rising.
In any way, the fact of the matter,
which we are now addressing,
remains that the global responses
has been too slow and too weak.
This is most oppressing task ahead of us.
I'm afraid to tell you
that young generation,
students like you,
you will soon be in charge
to address this issue
if my generation and
generation of professors
are not doing enough,
then I think it'll fall on your shoulders.
It can set also the stage
for a more insecure international order
in the post pandemic era.
So it has also something
to do with conflict,
political conflict.
Thankfully, a variety of
safe and effective vaccines
and other measures are being
distributed around the world.
This is incredibly encouraging
with over 11 billion total
vaccine doses administer to date.
Coupled with a continuation
of proactive measures,
such as testing, masking,
ventilations, therapeutics,
vaccines represent the
global communities best hope
of ending this pandemic.
But at the moment,
only about 66% of the global population
mostly those in wealthy nations
have received just one
jab of COVID 19 vaccine.
I have got four vaccine jabs.
I think most of you, I was
told that Professor Wilkinson,
Professor Kim?
- [Kim] I got three.
- Three, okay.
I'm better than you.
(audience laughs)
But in any way, if you
go to Africa, just a 16%,
16% all covering African people,
they have just one jab, one vaccine.
This is a reality.
This is both shameful
and counterproductive
as we strive to sustain
sustainably, persevere
over this pandemic and return
to semblance of normality.
Indeed global leaders have a moral
and humanitarian obligation
to rectify the current situation
of a gross vaccine and treatment
inequality and injustice.
We need to urgently come
together in solidarity
to vaccinate the world
and end this pandemic.
And we must remember no one is safe
until everybody is safe.
That's a fact.
If your family member,
or if one of your friends is infected,
then you can easily be affected.
Therefore you must make sure
that everybody should be safe.
With this in mind,
all nations should enhance support
for the UN COVAX mechanism
in its submission
to get vaccines to those in need.
It is wonderful that countries
like the United States
and Europe see some hope as
the virus becomes endemic,
yet largely treatable with
the vaccines and therapeutics.
But we must remember
that this virus remains formidable enemy
and not to let our guards down,
especially as much of the
world remains unprotected.
With this in mind, again,
I reiterate the UN Secret
General, António Guterres appeal
for a global vaccination
plan to double production,
and which at least 70%
of the world's population
by mid-2022, just two months.
We have both the resources
and ability to do so,
but lack the political will.
I have found during my of tenure service
at the United Nations,
it is just because of
lack of political will,
the political leaders do not have
such a firm determined will.
If they show some determination,
then I think we can handle this matter
much, much earlier and easily.
Dear students and professors,
let me just now go back to
the origin of the problems
that is climate change phenomena.
You must have heard many times that
since the industrialization
about 200 years ago,
humanity has achieved
remarkable economic growth
and technological progress.
However, in the process,
serious environmental damage occurred
and global warming and
climate change has ensued
as a result of reckless
human-made carbon emissions.
As biodiversity and habitats are destroyed
due to environmental destruction
wild animals have increasingly
become into contact
with the humans.
And as a result, novel viruses
and pandemic have spread.
Indeed, nearly all of the viruses
that have emerged in the 21st century
from SAR in 2000, to COVID 19 recently,
share the characteristics
of being common infectious diseases
between humans and animals.
The degradation of our
ecosystem by human beings
in the name of development.
I think we have become
very close to animals.
There's the main reason why
we are suffering from now.
In 2021 alone,
historic rain dramatically
deloused Central China
and in the Mediterranean
has been in flames with
a terrifying wildfires
burning in Greece, Turkey, Africa.
I think Western Coast of United States
has also suffered a lot
because of these wildfires.
The catastrophic flooding submerged
parts of central Europe
like Germany, Belgium,
underwater last September, last summer.
I was told that the flood,
which devastated some part of Germany
was such first one in
1000 years, 1000 years.
You may not believe it, but is
science which had determined
that it was the worst case
in 1000 years in Germany,
in such a prosper, wealthy countries.
The five hottest years of
globally recorded temperatures
have now all occurred since 2015,
during last seven years.
July 2021, last year,
was the earth's hottest
month ever recorded.
The fifth extension
people saying that may...
The sixth extension may
occur in hundred years
if we not take urgent action.
Then when this fifth
mass extinction happened,
what does this mass extinction means?
65 million years ago, most of the animals,
including dinosaurs just perished.
65 million years ago.
Then why we have to suffer
from this sixth mass extinction
in just a hundred years.
This is not my warning.
This is the warning of scientist
and climatologist and geologist.
So we have to make sure
that within 100 years,
I think we may not be here at that time,
but some of your grandparents
and great grandparent,
I mean, sons, daughters
will suffer from this mass extinction.
Geologists say that mass extinction
means that at least 70% of all species
will perish when it happens.
We have to really do much, much more
to prevent this kind of a mass
extinction from happening.
Here in the United
States, you know very well
the realities of rapidly
accelerating climate crisis
Summers are getting
both longer and hotter.
And the frequency and
intensity of flooding, storms,
and heavy heatwaves is
increasing each and every year.
Warming is not just a future threat.
A landmark study released recently
in the scientific journal, The Nature,
says that nearly 37% of all
global heat-related death
can now be blamed on
human-caused climate change.
How can we mitigate these dire threats?
Western nations, such
as the United States,
United Kingdom of European Union
certainly cannot do it alone,
nor can Asian countries,
Korea, Japan, China
can do it alone.
What is needed is an
unprecedented global effort
propelled by multilateralism,
solidarity, and partnership.
At least in our common effort,
we lost four years, at least four years,
during the time of Trump administration,
I'm not here to criticize any nations.
When I was Secretary-General
at the United Nations,
I was very careful not
to directly confront
any member state or head of state.
Now I'm a private citizen.
(audience laughing)
I have been speaking out quite frequently
that President Trump's decision
to withdraw from the Paris
Climate Change Agreement
was first of all, politically,
very shortsighted,
and economically, very irresponsible.
Scientifically speaking, dead wrong.
And I wondered, his name
will remain in the wrong side of history.
I have been speaking out.
How much time, and energy,
and passion, and difficulties,
and challenges I have
experienced during 10 years
to make sure that climate
change would be agreement.
You do not understand how
difficult it has been.
195 state parties assigned,
but this is almost unprecedented
way of decision-making.
Normally you make decision by majority,
or two-third majority, or you
can go three-quarter majority,
but normally, two-thirds majority
is most a difficult process,
but this is a hundred
percent absolute unanimity.
Even a single country
could kill the decision.
That might have happened in reality.
At the last minute of the gathering,
I thought that everything was ready.
Everybody was ready,
but there was only one country
who was indicating that
they would not support it.
There was a big crisis.
John Kerry, myself, other Americans,
everybody went to that delegation
really wanted to, if
we can break the neck.
But lastly, through
some sort of negotiation
between myself and the party concerned,
we were able to finally
adopt this agreement.
And I made sure that it came into effect
before I leave the United Nations.
It was just a matter of
one and a half a month,
one and a half a month.
My term ended just one
and a half a month later
after this Paris Climate
Change became effective.
It is a law.
It's a treaty.
Two months later,
as soon as when President
Trump came, he just withdrawn.
But fortunately, just US withdrawal
didn't affect the existence
and effectiveness of this agreement.
Had it not been effective,
and Trump redo from this,
then we would not have climate
change agreement even now.
It might have been very,
very difficult moment.
And when President Biden just joined
as he's the first president
to rejoin the Paris
Climate Change Agreement,
I really had the sigh of deep relief.
This is real story I'm telling you
from my own experience.
In any way, ladies and gentlemen,
I still believe that Paris Agreement
offers us our best hope
to persevere of the serious
threats to our planet,
but we must urgently step
up implementing commitment.
We don't have a planet B
because don't have a plan B.
We have only plan A
because we don't have another planet B.
This is something which I
have been repeating saying.
You may quote this one,
I don't claim any copyright or whatever.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have no time to lose.
This overing IPCC report
released in March this year,
explicitly concludes by warning that,
"Any further delay in consorted
anticipated global action
on adaptation and mitigation
will miss a brief and rapidly
closing window of opportunity
to secure a livable and
sustainable future for all."
This is what the IPCC,
composed of more than 2000
scientists, climatologists
has been repeatedly warning.
So we must listen to the
voices of scientists.
Doing so will be the difference
between either charting a secure
and prosper future for
students, such as yourselves
and our next generation.
If we do not do that,
we will embark on a future
that condemns young people
and their children to a planet
besieged by flames, heat, and flood.
What happens is up to us.
But I'm again saying that we must act now.
With this in mind,
in order to faithfully
implement the Paris Agreement
and push it even further,
all stakeholders need
to expand their actions
to cut emissions
and expect the rapid decarbonization
of the global economy to
achieve carbon neutrality.
Fortunately, many countries,
including the United States,
European Union, Republic of Korea, Japan,
I think they have announced
the carbon neutrality 2050.
China has announced
carbon neutrality 2060.
India has announced 2070,
that I am very much disappointed.
World leaders have understood
the Chinese commitment by 2060
was accepted and understood,
But when India said 2070,
that has really shaken
and destroyed full commitment
during COP26 in Glasgow last year.
Our target was that by the end of 2050,
this carbon neutrality should be committed
then because of India...
Just as I said, one country
can kill all this agreement.
There was no other way
but to agree by saying
that around the middle of
the century, not by 2050.
So it was a little bit watered down,
and there was no agreement
for financial contribution
by the rich countries.
I'm deeply concerned
and deeply disappointed
that United States and European Union,
they have not kept their promise,
which they made publicly in 2009.
Just how many years?
13 years has passed.
They promised that they would provide
a hundred billion dollars
every year by 2020.
Then by this time hundred
billion dollars should be ready
to be distributed to
developing countries now,
but even just 13 years after
they are not still keeping their promises.
This is the lack of political will,
what I have been always
criticizing publicly
to the member state.
And I'm again urging that big
countries, rich countries,
first, United States, and
European Union, and Japan,
and including Korea too,
they have mobilized at least
a hundred billion every year.
So ladies and gentlemen,
what I'm just trying to say is that
we have to do all what we have to do.
You may feel that you
know, I don't understand,
or I don't have any responsibility,
but I think there are some ways
which you can help at this time.
You may quote me, you may quote IPCC,
but you may raise your
voices to your governors,
to your senators, and
parliamentarians, and your presidents.
Then tell them that,
please make sure that this is the world
where I and my parent and my
sons and daughters will live.
So just make sure that during your time,
keep this promise, which you have made
carbon neutrality by 2050.
I think you have such a
power and raise your voice.
You see that my voice is
already very much down
because I have been always
speaking out like this way
with a passion.
By the end of the day, I'm
almost losing my voice.
I have been speaking all
the times like this way,
speaking out to the world leaders.
Now I'm relying on your power.
You have the vote.
If they are not committed,
you can change the candidate.
You can change the President.
This is your prerogative
as a citizens of the world.
Again, I'm really asking,
we simply must adapt and
act now or perish later.
Do you want to be perished?
Leaders must elevate their political will
for climate action, and industries,
and businesses must act in partnership
and leading educational institutions,
such as Yale University and
young people like yourselves
have a critical role
to play in this regard.
We need all hands on the tech approach.
Not a single person is exempt from this.
You may think that I'm just a student,
but you have the voting, right?
You have the voice again,
and you, the younger generation,
are the future leaders and global citizens
that I firmly believe
can lead us to brighter
and more sustainable and
more inclusive future.
Ladies and gentlemen, let me
just tell you as I conclude
about global citizenship.
I have been meeting so many world leaders.
They all claim that I'm the leader,
but I have not seen among them,
none many truly genuinely global leaders
with the global citizens.
At first, they are the national leaders.
What does then mean
then global citizenship.
Global citizens means that
those who identify themselves,
not merely as a member of the community,
but citizen of the world.
The passport you may carry,
your nationality does not
mean much at this time
with a transformative
development of communication,
transportation, information,
science, and technology.
I think we are living
in a very small world.
Wherever I'm speaking now
can be delivered to the
corner of the end of the world
within a fraction of a second.
Therefore, we are all living
in a very small world.
We are all global citizens.
When I was 18 years old boy,
I was very lucky boy at that time
to have been invited to White House
and met President Kennedy John F. Kennedy.
I was not even able to meet
the mayor of my own city.
Young boy, I was one
of 140 global students.
What President Kennedy said,
"The political leaders do
not engage each other."
Of course, it was true during
the height of cold war.
Khrushchev and Kennedy were
not talking each other.
They were fighting.
The national borders do not mean much.
National borders meant much at that time.
There was strict restrictions.
So you could not go from
this country to another,
without passport or whatever,
particularly for Koreans
where we were belonging to
this free democratic society
were not allowed to visit
any communist country.
But what he said, you young
people can do much better.
The question was whether you are ready
to extend your helping hand.
That was inspiring, quite inspiring.
I thought at that time,
I was thinking, what should I do?
If I say that I wanted to
become the Secretary-General,
that's a lie.
I thought, what should
I do for my country?
Korea was very poor at that time,
just a few years after Korean war.
So I thought that I should
do something for my country,
the reconstruction and
development of my country.
That's why I became Secretary-General.
And foreign minister of Korea later,
when I became foreign minister of Korea,
I was thinking,
and my eyes were opening
wider than before.
Then I was thinking, what
could I do for the world now?
That's my confession.
If I had such ambition from young
to become Secretary-General
of the United Nations,
but I think for you now,
you may have some limited future dreams,
but you can be practical,
but you can have better visions.
But what is important at this time,
have some global vision,
and global citizenship in your heart,
that when you act as a global citizen,
I'm sure that you'll make much, much more
and better contribution
to address all these global challenges.
This is my message today to you
and I hope that we all work together
to make this world better.
We cannot just leave this way
to our succeeding generation.
You may think that you
are not responsible,
but at least you have a moral
responsibility as I am now.
I don't have any political
responsibility now,
but I have a moral responsibility.
You also do have moral responsibility
to work together in
solidarity, in partnership
to make this world sustainable
and more peaceful and prosperous.
That's your moral responsibility.
And let us try to make this world a better
Thank very much for your attention.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Participant] Everyone,
we'll take questions
from the audience.
If you could just raise your hand
so we can bring you the mic.
- Good evening.
Mr. Ban, Thank you, first of
all, so much for this talk
and for your efforts to
make our world better.
My name is (indistinct).
I am Fox International
Fellow here at Yale.
And as you spoke about
the global citizenship,
I consider myself as a global citizen,
at least because this fellowship
considers us folks fellows
as citizen ambassadors,
and I study diplomacy and
international relations
for 10 years.
And I consider communication
as the essence of diplomacy.
And as you spoke about
the race of our voice,
I, as young woman who intends
to join the United Nations,
I'm wondering how can I
make this voice heard?
Because one thing is to raise voice.
And the other thing is to be heard.
Thank you.
- There are many, many
ways for your children
or yourself to contribute
to a current world.
And I welcome anybody
who really want to be working
for the United Nations.
I think United Nations
is the most universal
and global organizations for
any young talented people
would be most welcome.
But there are certain
procedures and regulations.
So I hope you can just
make sure that all this,
first of all, prepare for
all these examination,
whatever test, then
opportunities are always open.
But there are many students
while I was serving
who really wanted to
start from internship.
This is also competitive,
quite competitive.
The UN selects at least 900,
1,200 interns every year,
three-month internship.
And there are many ways,
and many organizations are
opening these positions.
UN positions are always open to the world.
It's not only limited to a UN staff
whenever there is opening.
Therefore I think your
friends or whoever maybe
can have an opportunity,
but you must be prepared for that.
I hope that I have
addressed to your question.
- [Mary] Thank you so
much, Secretary-General.
My name's Mary Evelyn Tucker.
I teach at the School of the Environment
in the Divinity School.
And I would be so grateful
if you would comment
on the event that took
place at the United Nations,
when the Pope came to speak
and also his encyclical
Laudato si on the environment,
which has also called people
to a global citizenship,
but an intrical ecology
that brings people and
the planet together.
So I'd love to have your comment on that.
And thank you so much for your talk.
- So, is there question or comment?
- [Mary] The question is, Laudato si
is one of the most important documents
in bringing a moral force
together for the environment.
Many people feel it's unprecedented.
And I wanted to have your
comment on the Pope's,
both his speech at the United Nations,
but also the encyclical,
which he wrote to affect
the Paris Agreement
in December of 2015.
- I think as of now, Paris Climate Change
sets very walkable...
I don't think it is most ambitious,
but it is a walkable path
to address climate change.
And there are many, many ways
we can further strengthen
based on this Paris
Climate Change Agreement.
Even reaching to this agreement
had to make many
concessions and the some...
So all negotiation, for example,
all negotiations are not perfect one.
I don't think the Paris
Agreement is a perfect one.
Even with imperfect one,
people are not implementing, as I said.
If we do all what is said
in the Paris Agreement,
I think we can at least
prevent such a catastrophic consequences,
but even in including United States
are not keeping all commitment faithfully.
For example, one thing really
disappointed me recently
is only nature and absolutely
right and necessary.
We provide humanitarian
assistance to people of Ukrainian.
They deserve our support,
but that doesn't mean
that this money for humanitarian support
are slashed from climate
fundings, climate funds.
US has promised 11 at
least $11 billion a year
for climate out of a
hundred billion dollars.
Then President Biden
just to cut $10 billion
out of 11 and sent to Ukraine first.
Of course, saving lives
may be much more urgent,
but saving our planet is also urgent.
Many European countries are
now slashing such fundings
from climate fundings.
That is what I have been
speaking out and criticizing
through my oped or my speeches.
This is shortsightedness.
So don't blame that Paris climate changing
may not be a perfect one.
There is no such a perfect
constitution, perfect laws.
This is all out of a negotiation.
We could have been much,
much more ambitious,
much, much tougher, but that
was all I could have done.
Do you know how many years has it taken
from since 1992 Kyoto Protocol 2015,
it almost took 30 years.
1992 Kyoto Protocol
was the result out of almost
a 10 years negotiations.
Then Kyoto Protocol became almost useless
because US did not join.
US signed it but was not ratified
by the Parliament, Senate.
So Al Gore, as a vice
president, he proudly signed it,
but it became useless
for the United States
and then means when US didn't join,
then Kyoto Protocol become almost dead
from the moment it became effective.
So there was a lot of such
frustrating processes,
and that's why as soon as
I became Secretary-General,
I made it number one top priority.
And I first tried to convince
President Bush at that time.
He was not convinced, but at
the end, he was convinced.
He was convinced.
And I was very much grateful to him
because he just added his voice.
Reluctantly then made
the beginning of success.
Since he said yes, then it
took nine years from 2007,
then 2000 until 2015.
As I said, I don't know, I
felt how much I was lucky
because that was adopted
before Trump came in.
If Trump joined this
presidency a little earlier,
I don't think we have, even now,
we don't have this
climate agreement, yeah.
Again, there is no such
a perfect one, yeah.
- [Participant] That's
a follow-up question
to the previous question.
So Catholic church has
more than 1 billion members
around the world, and-
- 1 Billion, 1 billion.
- [Participant] 1 Billion.
So do you think there's any
role the Catholic Pope can play
to really enforce this Paris
Environmental Agreement?
- The religious leaders have
a very important role to play,
and I am deeply grateful to Pope Francis
in making sure that 1
billion Catholic believers,
I mean, churchgoers.
He instructed,
and I discuss this matter
with the Pope himself
at the United Nations, as
well as in Rome Vatican,
I visit Vatican two, three times,
to make sure that Catholic
community would join.
And he issued his decree
to all 1 billion Catholics.
That really helped a lot.
I forgot the name of this
decree, but in any way,
after that, I went to
Vatican after my retirement.
I think ambassador Kim, he was with me
to pay my great thanks to him.
Then another contribution he made
was he came to the United Nations twice,
according to all history
of the United Nations,
all the popes, previous popes,
they came just once in
their pope leadership,
once to the United Nations.
Then current Pope Francis
is the only exception.
He came twice to urge member state
to agree on associated with development
and to agree on climate change.
He gave such a full
blessings, full blessings.
Of course, he's not a politician,
so he could not exert
the political pressure,
but he has given his full blessings.
I think I'm still very much
grateful for his intervention.
Yeah, thank you.
Yes.
- Hello, Mr. Ban.
Thank you so much for coming here.
My name is Eli, and I'm
a second-year MBA student
of Yale School of Management.
First thing, I do feel much better
as a private citizen
after hearing your speech.
At least I can say something
if I feel something is wrong.
and I feel your pain
as a Secretary-General
of the United Nations, and
you need to try your best
to keep everybody stand together.
Second, I do have a question
for your forward-looking plan
as the President of the
Ban Ki-Moon Foundation.
Do you have any plans
to continue the Carbon
Neutralization Initiative
for the next step?
- So, what do you want about
Ban Ki-Moon Foundation?
- So, for the next step,
do you have any plans, or do
you want to share any thoughts
how do you want to utilize this platform?
- I should confess that
this Ban Ki-Moon Foundation
was established just three years ago,
with some humble commitment
that I should do whatever I can
to make our future better for everyone.
This is a small foundation
composed of some small group of people,
but I have a limited
capacity in doing that.
I am using my role as a
former Secretary-General,
my moral voice,
working in close
cooperation and association
with the other organizations
and governments.
When I was introduced by professor Kim,
I'm now holding many
and different positions.
For example, when it comes to climate,
I am Chairman of Global
Center on Adaptation.
There are two policy responses to climate.
One is mitigation and adaptation.
Mitigation, we know that
we have to mitigate.
We have to reduce carbon emissions,
but how to invest wisely for the future
to prevent any future
disruptive climate consequences,
that is adaptation.
For example, when you build
the buildings, infrastructures,
when you build the street, I mean roads,
or when you plant to some crops,
then how can you solve these
climate-resilient crops?
Or how can you build
climate-resilient buildings
and infrastructures?
There are many ways we can save money
from future possible
destruction caused by climate.
Those are the much more,
I mean, better ideas.
I'm working as a chairman of this one.
And as I said, I'm
working also as a chairman
of this Global Green Growth Institute.
And I'm also working in other...
I'm using all different organization.
I'm also working as a chairman
of this Ban Ki-Moon Center
for Global Citizens.
Global citizenship, we don't
have any tools or resources
like you build a house or whatever,
but we teach them what needs to be done
to prevent further disruptive consequences
caused by climate change.
And we also just try to urge
world leaders to empower women,
empower youth, protect the human rights
and do much more on climate issues
and make a sustainable
development, etcetera, et cetera.
I'm using my voice as a
former Secretary-General.
These are something which I am doing.
So if you add your voices,
and I have the much, much...
I have a stronger voice,
stronger microphones, so to say.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, yeah.
- So we're gonna have one more question
and then we prepared the
reception on the second floor.
So all of you are welcome to join
and keep asking
Secretary-General more questions.
Okay, one more question.
Hwansoo, do you wanna
pick the last question?
- Somebody?
(audience laughing)
- The most difficult decision to make.
Okay, you and you,
maybe you can explain your two questions
and maybe Secretary-General
can answer together.
(speaking faintly)
- Thank you, Secretary-General,
for your speech.
I'm Chris, an undergraduate
student from South Korea.
I think I speak for everyone in this room
when I say you are a
symbol of collaboration
for worldwide collaboration
and global collaboration.
The COVID 19 pandemic has
changed our individual lives.
But in addition,
we've seen that it requires
us to work together,
to wear masks, to get vaccinated,
to be aware of spreading
the disease to others.
I see all of these as
acts of collaboration.
Have you seen any instances
where the pandemic has
changed collaboration
on the global level
and has it affected
collaboration between countries?
- So, you are now talking
about all these vaccine issues now.
- [Chris] How it has changed
the way we negotiate issues globally.
- I have not been engaged
in this negotiation
since I'm out of United Nations,
but during my time,
whenever such kind of global
health problems happened,
of course, I had to work
very close with WHO.
WHO is the main organization
which deals with all these
global health issues.
But WHO, frankly speaking,
is a very small organization
among 16 specialized agencies.
They're a bigger organization,
but they are mostly research organization
and doesn't have operational capacities.
So that's why from the beginning,
there was some problems in
addressing pandemic issues.
I immediately thought that the WHO,
you may know president Trump
has been criticizing WHO,
then maybe half right, half wrong.
But why I'm critical is that
president Trump was wrong
in withdrawing instead
of supporting the WHO.
Whatever mistakes or some visa
handling at the beginning,
there may be.
US should have given much bigger
and stronger support for WHO
rather than just withdrawing
and cutting funding.
Then WHO couldn't have any role to play.
Then I telephone as a
former Secretary-General,
I telephone Dr. Tedros,
WHO Director-General,
look, this is going to
be a very serious issue.
I telephone March 2020 or March of 2020.
You better walk and consult
with the Secretary-General
of the United Nations
and mobilize a whole United
nations organization.
Only Secretary-General can mobilize all,
not the Director-General of WHO.
If US intervened from the beginning,
I think US could mobilize
such a global run.
That's a US President
and Secretary-General
of the United Nations,
I think there are two
who can mobilize global
resources, but he didn't,
and President Trump withdrew,
just cutoff fundings.
That's the beginning of
worst things happening now.
I already learned from the beginning.
Now, looking back,
I think we must learn all
these lessons from failures.
We failed, in fact,
we could have prevented
it much, much quicker,
much more effective way.
And I think I said that
this is an issue of justice.
Just vaccinating American
people didn't mean much
because viruses do not
care about the borders.
People have been traveling
at the beginning,
at the beginning, and
therefore we had learning.
If you do not learn from the past failure,
you are apt to repeat the same things.
In 2014, when Ebola
broke out in West Africa,
the United Nations just took
one day to make a decision,
while coronavirus case,
it took four months.
There was a big difference
from one day to four-month.
The Security Council, I reported
to the Security Council.
Look, this Ebola,
which is now shipping
through Western Africa,
is not normal one.
We must take urgent action,
mobilize all the resources.
The Security Council,
there was the reason why Security Council
is involved in these health issues
because health can create
lot of global security issues
like COVID 19 has been doing.
The Security Council adopted
urgent resolution by one day,
that Ebola is a serious threat
to international peace and security.
Of course, they mentioned health issues,
but is a issue of peace and security.
We organized Ebola mission.
United States sent 7,000
soldiers, military soldiers,
French 500, United Kingdom 750 soldiers.
They were all dispatched
immediately to Western Africa.
They barricaded all borders.
Then there were not much traffic
among these infected areas.
And I myself risked my
life to visit the areas.
I was quarantined the
21 days after returning,
but United Nations and World
Bank didn't do anything,
not much.
This is the main reason
because Security Council,
because of the conflict between
United States and China,
China boycotted.
It took four months to
declare that COVID 19
is a serious threat to
international peace and security.
After four months,
most of the countries have been devastated
just to get in four months.
If there was an urgent
action blocking somewhere,
and if countries really
collaborated each other.
So this kind of China American conflict
even affected this global health issues.
So this is quite regrettable.
So we have to learn
all these hard lessons,
not to repeat.
Not to repeat in the future.
- Yeah, I hope the global leader
learned from this two-year-long
pandemic-like period.
Anyway, maybe I would give you the honor
to ask him in person on the second floor.
How did it sound?
Okay, thank you so much.
Thank you, Secretary-General,
for your wonderful talk.
(audience clapping)
Please give him a round of applause.
- So, thank you.
(upbeat music)